We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David Pakman. You know,
one of the blessings and simultaneously curses
that we've seen over the last four months
is that the audience has exploded in size.
That's a really great thing from the standpoint
of reaching more people. But it has also
brought in all sorts of new haters, trolls,
trumpets and tools of the right wing movement
that are regularly trolling me. And sometimes the
critiques are just really lame. Here's a guy who
could come up with nothing more creative to say
than my mouth is physically large. He
said my mouth is big. Listen to this.
Hello, I have a very quick question for
you, Pakman. Why is your mouth so wide?
But I'm not here to judge, I'm going to say,
look, I'm the perfect looking guy, but, you know,
it's a very interesting question. Why
why your mouth is at least, you know,
two hundred yards long. You can convert
that into metric if you want to die alone. I
greatly appreciate that many questions
as possible and thank you a lot.
Yeah, I mean, I think the answer is to answer
seriously. I think it's just genetics, right? I
mean, I assume I am the genetics of of my parents,
but this is the type of stuff that is I mean,
it's daily stuff like this. There's another guy
obsessed with the fact that I use my hands when
I talk. That's the big critique of the show. It
doesn't matter what I say, doesn't matter what
what anybody do. I'm using my hands when I talk.
So I'm hoping that a lot of these folks, as they
I think they may be on a comedown in a sense,
as they realize that Joe Biden's going to be
president. And so they still want to keep calling
in and attacking and engaging. But there's no
factual basis on which to engage with me because
Biden won and they're furious and all of that. So
instead they're focusing on stuff like this. It's
sad to see, but unfortunately, it's very, very
common. And to some degree, I believe we'll have
to continue dealing with it. We have a fantastic
bonus show for you today in California. There
is growing anger about stay at home orders. And
we are starting to hear from sheriffs who say they
will not be enforcing the stay at home orders. And
I have a lot to talk about regarding this. We also
now are seeing lab grown meat go on sale for the
first time. We've been covering lab grown meat for
a decade from when it was three hundred thousand
dollars for an ounce. And we said the price will
come down. This will be a thing in our lifetimes.
No kill lab grown meat is now going on sale
for the first time. We will talk about it.
And also very interesting revelations about
my accent. I have friends from the South
who say I have a New York accent.
Obviously, I don't. They just I
think a lot of us northerners sound the same
to them. I have people who write and say,
oh, David, you're based in Boston. I can hear
your Boston accent. I've never believed I had a
Boston accent. I didn't grow up in Boston.
And we finally have taken a dialect test
and the revelations are explosive. I hope
that they don't end the show because they
are controversial. But we will discuss all
of that and more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming
a member at Join Pakman dot com.